what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio at San Diego Comic-Con
2023 I am lucky enough to be sitting
here with the team behind Mother Nature
show those books off they're beautiful
in person beautiful in person
congratulations thank you so much all
right Jamie I'm coming your way first
because I was reading that you first
started thinking about this idea when
you were 19. it's a two-part question on
that what sparked the idea at 19 and now
that it's finished what is the biggest
difference between how you envisioned it
back then such a finished product now
see I told you that's why Collide are so
good
um I was 19 years old and I don't
remember the exact thing that happened
but I knew
that we were blowing it I knew that the
environment was telling us something I
knew at 19 a girl raised in La that
somehow we were on the wrong track and I
had this story
um in my head but I didn't really do
anything with it and then after I
finished the 2018 Halloween movie I got
my mojo back for independent filmmaking
storytelling I saw how creative David
Gordon green was
I started to write out the story I
started working with Russell my young
Padawan co-writer who then really took
the story into a different way really
reminded me that the story is called
Mother Nature I had made it more like a
father's knows best kind of story and we
turned it into together Mother Nature
about two mothers two daughters in Catch
Creek New Mexico where Cobalt electric
is coming up with a
a way of water purification
taking fracking water and making it
drinkable Greening the environment and
it was a story that we were working on
and Carl Stevens is an artist who I
collect the work of
and I sent him the story and he wrote
back and said it's a it's a graphic
novel so where it is today
is it's a much more graphic story it's
much more visual than it ever would have
been in my original idea it's very dark
um the
opening image that I am I'm showing you
is what happens uh in Catch Creek New
Mexico when an oil derrick breaks and
Slaughters the father of one of our
protagon well she's not really a
protagonist she's an antagonist uh one
of our characters in the book um so it
has gotten very deep very dirty very
bloody
um
viscerally
um Angry
and it is now fully realized in this
gorgeous book by Carl many many
follow-up questions to what you just
said up there Jamie and Russell one of
my absolute favorite things to talk
about in this industry is when two
creators find the ideal collaborator in
each other so can you tell me a little
bit about when you first met on
Halloween and also maybe something
specific you saw in the other that
signaled to you yes this is a good
partner in this business my story as I
said was Father Knows Best it was very
fathers the worker moms not the worker
blah blah blah and Russell who I had
started working with
came to me and said let me have a crack
at it and what he understood was that I
had missed this inherently important
part of it mother nature and and
he changed he he made this what it is
because it would not have been in my
version
there there are so many with a story
that deals with environmental themes
like I I there are so many like there
are 20 different parts of my brain that
are uh being pulled in different
directions about like the possibilities
of what this can be and I think the
collaborating with Jaime and the thing
that I love about it as an artist is
that Jamie always reminded me of what
her original conception was that this is
a ride with vicious gory kills and that
we can put a bunch of ideas in it but it
has to all be vocalized around that like
that that kind of righteous anger that
like very emotional perspective and that
that excited the hell out of me also
what Russell did
is that it takes place in an indigenous
population and I would have I
acknowledged it in my original version
but Russell literally came to me and
said we cannot do this we cannot make
this book with Carl unless we honor
and just explain a little of what you
did absolutely with that aspect of it
because it's all Russell uh we started
on the ground research for this book
four years ago or for this project four
years ago in New Mexico
um that's when we learned that this is
this takes place it's nicknamed Four
Corners because every a major form of
energy that has been harvested in
America is the remnants the skeletons
the it's all it's all still here and uh
a lot of it is on Navajo land and we had
collaborated with several Navajo artists
including Brian Lee Young Who wrote the
afterwards of this book
um and they uh they saw what we wanted
to do and they saw the emotional
perspective that we were speaking from
and they helped vocalize that and helped
uh tell that with uh their their
creation myths uh respectfully
um and help making sure that we were
serious and we understood their culture
and we understood the culture that we
were also representing because it's a
it's a very Multicultural story
you guys are doing a great job teeing up
so many different details I want to get
into more but first call I want to come
your way with a broader question because
I believe correct me if I'm wrong on any
of this you two wrote a script first and
then you saw the graphic novel potential
in that script so what was it about that
material that you thought would best be
brought to life in the graphic novel
format well the way that the script is
written was just so visual I mean all
the descriptions
um just really painted this like you
know incredible uh portrait of this this
place and this time and
um I just was immediately just like
getting ideas about
um like you know like how it would look
and like that you know I mean like that
really alone is what did it for me and I
mean you know of course like the message
I mean I've I've always wanted to do a
book that did uh address like the
problems of climate change because you
know I mean since I've been very young
I've been hearing about it and you know
I've just haven't had an opportunity to
really uh Express those concerns like
with my work okay now here's where I get
I hyper specific I hope you could answer
this but of everything you read in that
script is there any particular visual
that you were most excited to bring to
life via your work but then I also want
to know something that wound up being
more creatively fulfilling than you ever
could have imagined to draw
oh we got examples yeah I mean yeah I'm
like there are several um I like the
opening scene with the um oil rig uh
collapsing on the father's head
um beyond the hail storm too like that
that that alone was uh just an
incredible
um you know like like set piece to me
and
um you know I work in
um ink and watercolor so I thought that
I could make it uh like very like
painterly and it's like that that that
excited me that you know
it's beautiful You're gonna laugh but I
put on a wall
natural ways to kill people and then I
put on a wall characters and I did it
like with with index cards and you
remember those assignments as children
where they would put colors down a line
and then fruits and you had to draw the
line that corresponded to the fruit I
did that on my wall with string I was
like oh bud is gonna get
through his head on a black ice accident
um uh the the father of the football
player is going to get his head blown
off by hail storms and speaking of hail
storms I don't know about all y'all
but if you just go on YouTube or
Instagram and you just Google hail
storms recently the weather the climate
crisis has created these insane hail
storms and in hours
um can you hold this for one second
right there thank you so in ours for
instance a a football player is playing
football with his father the hail Begins
the father gets it whole plays the oh
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait the father gets it the Sun
gets it and then the aftermath
is I just had it oh wait I'm doing it
backwards I'm like the bad Carol Merrill
um and then you know this is the result
of what happens it's it has to be thank
you it has to be
we have to pay attention and the
Beautiful part of a graphic novel is
that it forces you to pay attention
because it's graphic
it's it's a graphic
interpretation of ideas and I think Carl
does also these gorgeous vistas of what
the world should look like the world the
way the world looked and can look again
if we pay attention and the Grim reality
of what in fact is happening